[Musique]
et Athis arrive tranquillement en
plateau bonsoir à tous Alors vous êtes
venus avec Loulou un chien oui croisé
bouvier bernois
avec Loulou pour vous donner des
conseils de l'Est ce soir
alors je le rappelle juste vous êtes
conseillère municipal en charge du
bien-être animal pour la ville de Poissy
et alors c'est très important de
promener son chien en laisse ces mêmes
obligatoires il me semble à this tout à
fait donc promener son chien est une en
laisse c'est une obligation qui est
imposée par par le maire et qui peut
être sanctionné si le chien n'est pas
tenu en laisse et voilà un chien en fait
il peut être détaché uniquement s'il est
vraiment très sociable sociable avec les
autres animaux mais également avec les
humains
et puis c'est surtout pour des notions
de sécurité et du coup c'est tout à fait
pour des notions de sécurité le chien en
fait vous pouvez discuter avec quelqu'un
pendant ce temps-là il peut être
perturbé par un autre un animal ou un
autre humain et puis partir sur la route
il peut se retrouver écraser percuté par
un véhicule mais également on peut
assister des fois à des chiens qui
croisent des copines et puis profond
tout un show on se retrouve les uns dans
les autres donc c'est vraiment de la
sécurité pour avoir votre chien à côté
de vous donc vaut mieux tenir son chien
en laisse et alors est-ce qu'il existe
différents types de laisse comment
comment est-ce qu'on fait pour pour
choisir sa laisse alors il existe
beaucoup beaucoup de types de laisse en
fonction de son usage l'écouter avec
Loulou ce soir on va vous présenter
quelques laisse je vous en prie voilà
et très sage et s'est installé
donc il a 8 ans notre loulou il fait 45
kg donc là ça c'est une laisse en fait
qui est assez confortable avec des
anneaux qui évitent à ce qui est des
chocs quand vous le vous le tirez donc
il y a pas de il y a pas de souci bien
loulou tu verras maman après
et non quels sont les autres types de
l'esthétisme on va tester les autres
lettres donc vous avez
des laisse qui sont donc là il y a une
NES qui est un peu plus courte avec une
particularité son mousqueton parce qu'il
y a des chiens qui peuvent enlever son
fur avec le mousqueton donc celle-là il
peut pas se détacher du mousqueton donc
celle-là elle est un petit peu plus
courte voilà un petit tour la poignée
elle est vraiment très confortable la
poignée c'est vraiment quelque chose un
élément qui est très très important
puisque vous pouvez vous blesser
vous-même en tirant le chien on va
tester notre laisse on a l'impression
c'est plutôt pour les grands chiens
alors
aussi pour les petits chiens en fait
elle s'étire elle va jusqu'à 2 mètres
vous avez différentes marques j'ai
vraiment essayé des lettres qui sont
vraiment de qualité parce qu'il faut pas
prendre n'importe quel laisse loulou on
y va
ensuite on va tester une autre laisse et
puis je vous dirais qu'elle a la laisse
que j'ai préféré pour loulou donc loulou
lui il sort trois fois par jour quand
c'est mettre sont au travail et 4 fois
quand ils sont à la maison et quand ils
sont en télétravail c'est plus Émeline
qui sort au loulou pendant que Stanley
au jardin il fait du compost donc
compost donc celle-là aussi elle est
vraiment très agréable vous avez un zip
où vous pouvez mettre le canisa que à
l'intérieur c'est une laisse de ville et
puis vous pouvez mettre votre petite
pièce pour aller acheter votre baguette
chez le commerçant puisque maintenant
les commerçants la plupart accepte que
vous rentriez avec votre animal à
l'intérieur oui ça c'est plutôt pratique
du coup et puis alors il y en a deux
autres à tester donc il y a celle-ci
alors moi au départ je croyais que
c'était une laisse en cuir pour les
chiens pantouflards en fait non pas du
tout c'est une laisse qui est vraiment
qui est une matière qui était faite pour
pour les chevaux et les
comportementsalistes conseillent cette
laisse pour les chiens qui tirent
énormément donc vous pouvez le maîtriser
elle est incassable et si la laisse
tombe dans la crotte et ben vous elle
n'a pas d'odeur vous avez juste un coup
de savon à passer et voilà il y avait
plus rien louloute est fatigué
il a dit j'en ai marre de tourner en
rond là-bas
et vous avez une dernière l'année
dernière laisse
donc celle là c'est une laisse spécial
canicross c'est pour ça j'ai laissé sur
sur la fin alors
c'est facile à mettre donc maintenant
c'est la mode tout le monde va courir
avec avec son chien donc là vous allez
avoir les mains libres vous allez
pouvoir vous attacher
loulou on va courir tu bailles juste
avant
voilà donc c'est réglable vous pouvez le
mettre autour de la taille vous pouvez
mettre également sur le côté vous avez
les mains libres vous avancez donc voilà
hop comme ça vous ne perdez pas en forêt
ou plutôt lui vous perd pas parce que
lui il va courir plus vite que vous
et du coup il y a pas de enfin faut
quand même éduquer son chien parce que
sinon on risque de se faire tracter non
si le chien il a envie de courir comment
ça se passe ou éduquer son chien donc
celle-là déjà je vais sélectionner
spécialement pour nos chroniqueurs du
sport je pense que celle-là elle est
bonne pour le sport au niveau de
l'éducation donc il faut déjà s'habituer
déjà à la maison vous lui mettre le
collier avec la laisse pour qu'il
s'habitue également au niveau de au
niveau de son poids et quand vous
avancez vous faites un pas et que lui
est parti beaucoup plus loin vous
attendez et puis lui revient en arrière
vous lui donnez le friandise vous
renouvelez à chaque fois avec lui donc
celle-là c'est vraiment pour pour loulou
on voit il est très sportif
pause donc il y a vraiment il faut
vraiment aller voir un professionnel
pour demander qu'est-ce qui est le plus
adapté à votre chien pour pas que le
chien ait des tensions aux détention
musculaires loulou bien c'est des cas il
visite
voilà donc vous avez des marques en fait
vous avez des garanties qui sont sur 20
ans vous avez des marques comme vous
avez kifly rocks vous avez la marque
EQUIS donc c'est vraiment des marques de
qualité allez en animalerie pour voir un
conseiller qui vous dira vraiment il
faut qu'il vous posera des questions par
rapport au caractère de votre chien par
rapport à l'usage c'est comme les
chaussures vous avez pas mettre des
chaussures à talons et des chupeurs de
basket tout le temps donc faut changer
et je vous conseille d'avoir deux laisse
avec vous parce que si on a une qui se
cassait vous avez une autre laisse de
sécurité et ben on va vous laisser
revenir tranquillement en plateau à
tisse avec
Loulou du coup faut vraiment marcher
du coup oui vous nous avez présenté
plusieurs matières plusieurs types de
laisse donc c'est vraiment en fonction
de son chien qu'on va choisir finalement
ça laisse tout à fait en fonction de son
chien de l'usage et bien merci beaucoup
à tous pour toutes ces précisions et
merci aussi loulou pour la démonstration
vous revenez bientôt peut-être avec une
autre chronique oui je reviendrai bateau
avec une autre chronique et peut-être un
autre animal sur le plateau et bien ce
sera avec plaisir